міністр за кордон та право євросоюзу
приїхали на свою астану у тимура
зустріч брюсселі
сайт харчування кіно мазалася ви вирішить його
з 2000 15 столітті ви машину переноситься на
успішного в занурення мінська думав про нас
три як самці буди розправляючи міністра
законність про поза машиною
франк-вальтер штайнмайєр сенс середам у
себе на підготовці правового пит грунті
для місяців їх вибору в зоні конфлікту з
чим відведуть asiana уві сні наступна уроку
c харчування просувається навіть по вільну
червона одягаюсь а ще через взяти з
титану полів заздрістю ми досягнемо вони
обхідного успіхів а б вибір іди снів
далося ж провести наступна на уроку
сні я є фольга повір
напрошується на тільки підготовка до
виборів до 30 п а шо грудня роббінс
пункті в мінську води на сто п'ятсот
кивнувши значок на
розділення у вогні деталях ти ніші
порушити і ведмеді на ос брови не годину в
годину у paradise лукавий побоїще до лінії
протестуючи не
україна до сильного 3 мало контроль над
своїм з єхидним кордоном та й на
дріт стати іншу реформу повного
обміну заручником це повна нам це
шкірний вигляд був осі yaw і висновків не зданий
басу вусики на задніх збійних формувати
гуманітарно ситуація така завищена
багата красиво
цивільно носила не потім наша місії
стикалася по б два бог і повільніше
протистоянням сказала нам що хочеш
паку хочеш щоб наріжте піднесучи
обстріли він і покараю що за лінію у вогні
терористи годину апарат їсть його покараю
що у севан та українці у них майже не
пори бій засвітло водою і розум особливого
складного поля в цій дамі в чохол
одну пару рук у я сам ще нас донбасу
бо чого дебальцеве мулі корінням там душі
складно ситуація на vista чайна від
препаратів для анестезії 7 за 1 годину
мінську туманності зберігаю статус-кво та
на захід головної бази силоси протестів
поки що домагаються закуповує і маріуполь
український скронь це шкірне вдаються
борг тильних наступальних день
статус-кво також означає
через фігні санкції проти росії моїх
but i художник так касла коньячний янгол
маркет висовувалася за заощадження
санкцій чекаю повного виконання мінських
домовленостей